le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais l'agriculture est à la
Réunion un secteur porteur créateur de
richesse et
d'emploi les agriculteurs contribu aussi
à aménager le territoire à façonner nos
beaux
paysages par ailleurs ils produisent des
produits sains bon pour la santé mais
qui sont trop souvent encore
concurrencés par des importations à
moindre coût
alors comment aider les agriculteurs à
faire connaître leurs produits comment
faire découvrir au citadins les
richesses de la production
locale on en parle maintenant dans lien
social le quartier du bas de la rivière
à Saint-Denis était autrefois un lieu à
vocation industrielle et
agricole il a activement participer au
développement du chef-lieu de la
réunion très actif ce quartier a été
fortement peuplé et très
urbanisé mais les fermetures successives
des usines ont considérablement réduit
la fréquentation du quartier presque
laissé à
l'abandon le Conseil général a souhaité
redonner vie au bas de la rivière et en
faire un écoquartier pilote expérience
qui pourrait ensuite être développée sur
d'autres
communes après des aménagement urbain et
la renaissance du collège redley il
s'agit maintenant de relancer une vie
sociale dans ce lieu chargé
d'histoire le Conseil général a donc
cherché des solutions pour permettre aux
différentes populations de se retrouver
d'échanger de
partager c'est de cette conviction que
sont nés les marchés pays qui ont lieu
tous les 2è mercredi du mois à l'espace
redley l'objectif est d'apporter du
soutien aux agriculteurs réunionnais
dont certains exerçant à Saint-Denis en
leur offrant plus de points de vente et
permettre aux habitant du quartier de
redécouvrir les produits pays de
qualité Patrick est agriculteur depuis
25 ans il connaît bien les difficultés
que rencontre le monde agricole en
général et trouve que le marché pays est
une belle idée qui lui apporte un
soutien financier mais aussi
social on a pasz point de vente les
marchés fors bon des fois c'est loin des
fois c'est pas il y a trop de
concurrents et pour écouler les produits
très très difficile mais le marché là je
trouve c'est très très intéressant au
niveau contact avec les gens au niveau
de la vente même au niveau ben au niveau
financièrement pour le pour mon revenu
c'est un plus moi j'ai présenté le la
patole c'est un légume très très ancien
ben les gens on ils découvrent des
choses et aussi ont découvré notre
clientèle on a fait connaissance on a
discuté un petit peu pour voir on a on a
donné nos no nos idées aussi j'ai dit
aux responsables que c'est un truc faut
pas arrêter il faut pas arrêter faut
continuer parce qu'il rapporte quand
même quelque chose aux agriculteurs aux
artisans tout ça tout ce qui vient
viennent ici ah c'était très très bon
comme Patrick beaucoup d'agriculteurs
ont besoin de soutien l'aspect financier
n'est pas la seule raison d'aider le
monde agricole ce sont des métiers très
difficiles et la reconnaissance n'est
pas forcément au rendez-vous grâce au
marché pays les agriculteurs présents
sur les stands peuvent partager l'amour
de leur métier avec les clients ils
peuvent parler avec passion de leur
produits au grand bonheur des acheteurs
c'est une équation parfaite car le
client y trouve non seulement des
produits frais mais à meilleur prix car
c'est une vente directe entre
l'agriculteur et le consommateur les
produits à la Réunion sont bons de bonne
qualité avec même des produits bio et
nous avons beaucoup accompagné les
agriculteurs qui ont fait des efforts
considérable à la Réunion on mange bien
on produit bien mais il faut que le
consommateur lui-même y gagne et quand
on met en place ses marchés pays on
évite les intermédiaires du producteur
au consommateur c'est de la vente
directe ce qui permet également
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
familles réunionnaises tout en soutenant
la production locale et en soutenant le
bon manger créole avec les produits
frais le meilleur caris poulet ben c'est
le poulet pays hein donc voilà chaque
deuxèe mercredi du mois venait à
l'espace
redlé autrefois surnommé le grenier de
Saint-Denis le quartier du bas de la
rivière est en train de renouer avec le
mieux vivre et qu'au quartier en cours
il revit grâce à des animations
économiques et sociales le marché pays
est un formidable moyen de relier les
gens entre eux les population se
retrouve échange et partage elle
redécouvre des produits qui ont fait la
Réunion
C a les agcur et enant des produits à
meilleur prix
consmur le marché pays est un exemple à
suivre car il prouve que la solidarité
apporte des solutions à tous les acteurs
d'un même dispositif le marché pays
c'est tous les deè mercredi du mois à
l'espace redy au bas de la
rivière le Conseil générale de la
Réunion vous a présenté lien social le
Conseil général au côté des Réunionnais
s I can